let's bring in once Dennis who is uh
from the RAC Rod good to have you with
us and good morning so I mean what's
your advice to drivers who are dealing
with the Gateway obviously the roads are
going to be busy because more people
will be using them but with strikes
compounding uh the busyness yeah ready
strikes have been the tale of this
Christmas getaway I think Kamali I think
you know lots and lots of people heading
away over the next couple of days our
research here at the RAC suggests that
the bulk of drivers will actually cram
their getaway trips into uh the 23rd and
the 24th and around about 40 of all
getaway trips taken on those two days
and clearly one of those days or at
least at least one of those days
actually is covered by at least a rail
strike in clearly those National Highway
strikes as well so it's a pretty
difficult pitcher for drivers I think
this year the message as usual is plan
your trip carefully try to avoid the
busiest periods through the course of
the day if you can that normally means
getting away as early as you can in the
morning or leaving your trip until later
in the afternoon and obviously just make
sure your car's not going to let you
down as well we've seen a huge huge rise
in breakdowns in the last few weeks
partly brought about by the very cold
weather but that's continuing through
here now as well so you know nobody
wants to break down at the best of times
when we're all trying to get away to see
friends and loved ones making sure your
tires are all coolant those sorts of
things are all at the levels they should
be should hopefully guarantee more
straightforward trip so that's it check
the the card to make sure it's
functioning properly and just give us
those timings again I'm asking for a
friend my sister who is on her way down
in a couple of days
yeah we're expecting 40 of the bulk
that's a large proportion of getaway
trips to be crammed into the 23rd of the
24th around about 8 million separate
Leisure trips by car over those two days
and the times to avoid really the middle
of the day you want to head out as soon
as you can in the morning ideally sort
of by seven or seven o'clock in the
morning to get on the road or leave your
journey until later in the morning or
even in until even later into the
afternoon actually to try to avoid the
worst of the queues the reason we have
the jams we do is because everyone's on
the road at the same time and people
tend to get up slightly later when we're
sort of moving into sort of Christmas
mode so if you can get up nice and early
and get out on the road you're more
likely to have a straight Fortune I
think and a thought for me Rod then on
the strike by workers from the highways
agency they're staggering it in
different parts of the country
um how will that affect motorists
we hope that's not going to affect them
too badly actually
um it is obviously some some operators
uh who work into their control centers
um who are striking but it's clearly
part of a much bigger picture and in
fact the research we did here at the RAC
suggested it's the rail strikes that
will have a bigger impact of people uh
we spoke to around about 2 000 drivers 2
000 people rather last week and around
about a fifth of them said that their
trips getaway trips of Christmas have
been directly impacted by the rail
strike and they were having to move into
Road car based transport instead a
figure that Rose to nearly four in ten
young people so that just shows just how
sensitive that particular group is to
what's happening on the railways at the
moment clearly that's only part of
Christmas Eve that's going to be
affecting people but the whole sort of
message from sort of you know the public
transport sector of do not travel
because of short notice cancellations
and things is only going to really Force
more people into their cars people this
year who clearly want to make sure they
have a proper sort of Christmas and get
away for that in the normal way and I
think that's what people are still going
to do